Anthony: Hey guys.
Anthony here in St. Petersburg at
the Imagine Cup
I got Alessandro here with me who is
one of the guys from the Hateya team.
You guys have come up with such an
amazing idea.
Tell me a little bit about this.
Alessandro: So we have, imagine a system which
is inside the a
firefighter's equipment
with augmented reality glasses.
So
if a firefighter want to return to his
starting point an arrow is displayed through
the glasses.
Anthony: Where did this idea come from?
What made you want to do
this?
Alessandro: One day we saw on the news that
a
firefighter died because he didn't find the
the way out.
Anthony: And one of the things that's interesting
to me about this, is you couldn't rely on
traditional GPS
and positioning right?
Alessandro: You're inside the building so
the signal
doesn't pass.
So we have to tackle this problem through
sensors like the gyroscope, the
compass, and the accelerometers.
Anthony: You can send data to somebody outside
right?
Alessandro: Yeah that's right.
So we also have made a system outside the
building.
We call it the backoffice.
It's a Windows Store
application thats collect the data from the
solution
on the firefighter's jacket,
which is called the comeback, and so we are
able to to view the the cover path
of the fire fighters.
If firefighter need some rescue,
a signal is sent to the backoffice and
we establish a mesh architecture between
the comebacks in order to bring back the information.
So the supervisor outside the building can
send him somerescue.
Anthony: You can't just put standard electronics
in right?
Cause it's a fiery building.
Alessandro: Of course because the sensors
have to be treated for extreme heat and extreme
areas.
So there are some specialized companies that
do that.
Anthony: What percentage of a fire department's
budget would this be?
Alessandro: Full firefighters equipment costs
about four or maybe three thousand dollars.
With all includes the helmet, the shoes, the
jacket.
And we create our solution for about 10 percent
of this initial cost.
Anthony: For an extra three hundred dollars,
four hundred dollars, these suits get outfitted
with these sensors?
Alessandro: Yeah.
The technology is there an it doesn't exist,
so we have created.
Anthony: That's so cool.
You guys are doing such great work man thank
you.
Remember we have so much more from the Imagine
Cup all week.
If you're wondering what the Imagine Cup is,
we have a whole video explaining it over on
Rev3Games.
YouTube.com/rev3games
We're also covering a ton of the games competition
over there.
And be sure to subscribe here to Dnews for
more inventions from the floor.